alors vous êtes vraiment très très
nombreux à nous poser des questions mais
heureusement on peut pas répondre en
temps réel tout le temps je pense que ma
journée à faire sa marianne que
l'abandon le godbout merci d'être avec
nous marianne tout le monde on vous êtes
avoir 4 vous connaissez bien les milieux
de travail puis les questions
d'assurance emploi notamment le godbout
vous connaissez la fiscalité l'économie
les finances publiques les programmes
qui ont été présentés bien sûr par les
gouvernements au cours des derniers
jours alors j'y vais tout de suite avec
des questions qui nous ont été adressées
dans les dernières heures et derniers
jours est-ce que le goût de boules le
gouvernement offrira de l'aide
supplémentaire pour les non la pause et
entoure cette question là c'est mon
réalisateur on l'a posé cette question
lors pas ça la prochaine
est ce que le gouvernement offrira de
l'aide supplémentaire pour les retraités
ok alors pour les retraités comme tel il
n'y a pas de bonifications de la pension
de sécurité de la vieillesse et du
supplément de revenu garanti ou des
prestations du régime des rentes par
contre et le gouvernement du québec et
le gouvernement canadien a pour ou les
personnes âgées qui ont le faire donc le
fonds enregistré de revenu de retraite
c'est pour les personnes âgées de plus
de soixante et onze ans lorsqu'ils ont
converti leur erreur en faire on sait
que défaire sa prévoit des retraits
minimaux à chaque année donc chaque
année pour faire rentrer 1 minimal et
donc lorsqu'on vient faire compte tenu
de la situation économique la baisse des
taux d'intérêt la fluctuation du marché
boursier
on vient dire aux gens qu'ils le
souhaitent vous pourrez retirer pour
l'année 2020 25 pour cent de moins que
le minimum qui était initialement prévu
histoire de laisser de plus d'argent de
le faire pour le laisser croire pour
usage pour les années futures
attention luc de pau perdre l'ensemble
de vos outils c'est important de rester
avec nous un autre élément aussi tu
pourrais rajouter effectué pour les
aînés comme tout citoyen ils ont droit
aux crédits de tps
donc il ya les crédits de tps a été
bonifié cette semaine pour le prochain
versement
on parle de doubler les discréditer ps
annuel et de les bercer entièrement lors
du prochain versement
alors pour un couple de personnes âgées
qui n'ont pas de revenus de travail
on parle de bonification honte de près
de 600 dollars donc quand même une ied a
signalé qu'il applique à tous y compris
aux amis mais pas de changement sur les
rentes rrq rpc et sécurité de vieillesse
supplément de revenu garanti a pas de
changement là dessus non ok j'ai droit
au chômage mais avec les nouvelles
mesures fédérales
est-ce que l'écart entre la prestation
de chômage et mon salaire net sera
comblé par l'employeur marianne
plamondon
alors ya un programme qui existe dans le
programme de prestations supplémentaires
de chômage qui permet à un employeur de
combler cet écart là maintenant
l'empereur doit être enregistré auprès
de service canada et avoir fait la
première avoir reçu l'approbation de
service canada
si l'employeur le fait de son propre
chef ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que le
montant de l'assurance emploi vont être
réduits par le montant qui est reçu par
l'employeur donc les employeurs doivent
faire la procédure avant coup ok parfait
prochaine question j'aimerais savoir
pourquoi on n'envisage pas de demander
aux employeurs de ne pas licencier leurs
employés qu'ils veulent mais moi je veux
bien les deux alors luc godbout pas vrai
c'est marianne plamondon et est
indirectement le gouvernement fédéral a
mis en place une subvention salariale en
offrant 10 % des salaires versés pour
les petites entreprises qui vont être
payés par le gouvernement fédéral sous
forme de subvention au cours des trois
prochains mois
on parle dans le fond d'un maximum de
1375 dollars par employé grosso modo
dans un titre que si vous avez des
pauses en pot et qui sont payés en bas
de 55 mille dollars
il ya 10% des salaires qui vont être
payés par l'état et on parle de petite
entreprise de donc si votre masse
salariale est en moyenne de 40 mille
dollars par année par employé vous
pouvez avoir jusqu'à 25 employés qui
vont être couverts par cette mesure là
ça comprend les entreprises qui sont
couvertes par la déduction pour petites
entreprises ça comprend également les os
bl
ainsi que les organismes de bienfaisance
donc c'est une façon d'envoyer un signal
de ne pas faire de mises à pied mais
vrai que pour ça c'est pas suffisant
mais c'est
d'abord un premier geste qui était du
côté d'ottawa un ajout nature marianne
mais la réalité c'est que les employeurs
ont peur de ne pas pouvoir a quitté les
salaires compte tenu qu'ils recevront
pas le paiement de leurs factures aussi
rapidement qu habituellement ou encore
leurs activités sont diminués ce que
j'ai vu cette semaine surtout c'est que
les employeurs décident de mettre à pied
des mises à pied temporaires
c'est à dire que le lien d'emploi est
maintenu par contre on durant cette
période là ils ne reçoivent pas de
salaire de l'employeur et donc on évite
les salariés à aller vers l'assurance
emploi en espérant pouvoir les rap
l'idée que la crise est terminée et en
gardant le lien d'emploi
comment faire pour s'inscrire au
programme qui permettrait de maintenir
en poste mais trois employés le godbout
ses compagnes avaient un programme déjà
existant qui à l'assurance emploi qui
s'appelait de travers le programme pour
le travail partagé
alors ce programme a été revu pour que
les règles soient facilitées donne un
exemple vous avez cinq employés au lieu
de vouloir en mettre à la porte les cinq
employés décident de réduire le temps de
travail le google d'employeurs propose
cela est donc le ya un programme qui se
met en place et qui permet à tout le
monde d'avoir un peu d'assurance emploi
et de maintenir leur salaire de leur
travail
donc ce programme là c'est une bonne
chose comment le demande est là c'est
sûr que comme ça du temps c'est un peu
dur mais si on va sur le type de
canada.ca son cherche dans emploi
développement social
les avis qui ont été annoncées cette
semaine pour le coronavirus ça va vous
donner le lien ou la marche à suivre
pour faire 7 domaines
j'aimerais savoir si le gouvernement va
mettre des mesures pour prolonger le
chômage
marianne mais c'est une bonne c'est une
excellente question parce que surtout si
la crise et pour durer plus que quelques
semaines on sait que l'assurance emploi
c'est seulement 15 semaines
donc si la crise et pour perdurer on
peut pour croire que tous ces gens là
vont se tourner vers l'aide sociale
ça risque d'être une crise sociale donc
il va falloir prévoir de nouvelles
mesures à ce moment là le godbout est ce
que quelque chose sera fait pour les
familles qui sont locataires
il ya quelque chose qui est fait pour
les familles notamment en général pour
des enfants des familles qui sont à
faible revenu mais pour les locataires
spécifiquement si la question c'est de
savoir est ce qu'il ya
des annonces qui sont offertes pour
pouvoir reporter le paiement du loyer il
n'y a pas eu de non sens au sens mal qui
a été fait par les gouvernements se le
dise il ya une bonne entente avec le
locateur on peut toujours demander des
arrangements sont nos pertes de revenus
mais par contre corona pour les familles
en général
comme je le disais bonification du
crédit tpr bonification des locations
canadienne pour enfants donc si je
prends un ménage avec deux enfants qui a
droit au maximum de ses prestations là
on parle d'une bonification qui peut
atteindre 1000 près de 1500 $ et ça va
rentrer dans les prochaines semaines
donc il ya quelque chose pour les
familles mais pas nécessairement parce
qu'elles sont locataires